slow down that's the message from some
in north las vegas concerned about the
safety of their neighborhood jeremy j
ford joins us live from the newsroom
tonight with more on the plan to combat
speeding jeremy
thanks sasha well i spoke with residents
at lucy and lone mountain who tell me
although 25 miles an hour speed limit
signs are posted throughout the
community drivers often tend to drive
too fast
i want everybody to slow down down the
limits
a plea from little katie blue a child
that feels she can't safely ride her
bike in front of her house due to
speeders i always ask every single day
if i could go out here and ride my bike
but i can't because the toes are like
zooming through the drive area now her
mother nicole is asking drivers to slow
down it's a 25 mile per hour zone but
people are going anywhere between 60 to
80 miles per hour zooming past other
cars and causing accidents mainly right
around the stop sign area on washburn
and lawrence and lone mountain in
lawrence there's been a couple right
there at that accident because even
though there are stop signs there
sometimes people going too fast they
drive right through that stop sign
now rainey wants to start a neighborhood
petition to present to county officials
to get speed bumps installed to help
slow down drivers from the newsroom
jeremy j ford live local now